when someone wants to meet with you and
catch up with you for coffee or drink
you'll make time for them when was the
last time you made time for yourself
we're looking for somebody else's
approval to say it's okay to be you yes
I believe when you go you need to learn
to stop seeking that approval there is
no magic one-size-fits-all solution when
it comes to habits or happiness or
anything rise and shine it's an espresso
time what's up belief nation it's Evan I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so let's start your day
off right together grab your coffee and
sip on today's message get to know
yourself over to you dhandapani
[Music]
to know yourself is the greatest gift
you can give yourself truly we all spend
so much time with other people and other
things in life but we never invest any
time in getting to know ourselves when
someone wants to meet with you and catch
up with you for coffee or drink you'll
make time for them when was the last
time you made time for yourself how
would you know what you want in life if
you don't even spend time to get to know
yourself if you have a business you
would spend time to get to know the
client find out what the client wants in
order to provide the best service for
the client right so if you really want
to understand what you want in life if
you want to know what you want or what
your purpose in life is you have to
spend time with yourself you have to
learn how to concentrate because if you
can't concentrate you won't be able to
sit there long enough and figure out
what it is you want at life and once you
know what you want in life you take that
palace of concentration and that finite
amount of energy and you focus it into
what you want and that will start to
manifest in life and the byproduct of
that is happiness when you ask most
people what do you want in life
most people's response is happiness
happiness shouldn't be pursued happiness
ensues it comes as a byproduct of living
a certain way people don't want to spend
time with themselves to figure out what
they want because it forces you to be
held accountable
it's much easier to be told what to do
and then complain that the other person
didn't make the right call when the
decision doesn't work out it's a lot
harder to figure out what you want
recognize that you're still far away
from accomplishing your goals and then
take the personal responsibility to make
it happen until you do until you figure
out what it is that you want and own it
you'll never truly be happy but you'll
always have someone else to blame it's
time to decide what you actually want so
one of the most common questions that I
get asked when people read your one word
is that right in the mean they say
heaven what do you think about my one
word I think it could be this I think it
could be this what do you think Evan you
wrote the book what do you think I can't
answer that question this is a journey
into self-discovery nobody around you
can answer that question because they
only see one side of you I even have a
page in a book that talks about spend
less time talking to other people and
more time with yourself because for some
reason we default the saying hey what do
you think what do you think what do you
think as if we're looking for permission
to be ourselves we're looking for
somebody else's approval to say it's
okay to be you yes I believe when you go
you need to learn to stop seeking that
approval you need to learn to stop
seeking other people's permission to be
you and that's difficult that means you
need to own your life that means you
have to take responsibility and
accountability for where you are that if
you haven't hit your goals yet that it's
nobody else's fault that it's not my
fault if you can't find your one word
that it's not your friend's fault if
they haven't given you the right guide
and said it's not your boss's fault if
they haven't made the right decision for
you that if you are not where you want
to be in your life that it's your fault
and that sucks taking that personal
accountability but it's also awesome
it's amazing because now you are the one
in control when you accept that
everything is into your control when you
accept that accomplishing your goals is
your sole responsibility then it sucks
for where you are right now but it's
amazing because you can go off and
accomplish it because you don't need
that person's approval that person's
permission that person's guidance that
person's hand-me-down to help you get to
where you need to be this is on you now
and that's amazing so for example when
somebody comes and says that their one
word is freedom I'm
your one-word most important value is
freedom what does freedom look like to
you I have I have a definition of it if
you ask me what does freedom look like I
could define it in my own words that
doesn't matter what does freedom look
like for you how do you break it down
what are the three things that make up
your credo that make up freedom for you
and then how do you apply that to your
life so how do you apply freedom to your
relationships how do you apply freedom
to your business to your career how do
you apply freedom everywhere in your
life because if you are not happy if
there's an error in your life that you
are not happy and you figured out what
your one word is that's the lens that's
gonna tell you why if you are not happy
in your relationship right now and your
one word is freedom it's because you
don't have enough freedom in your
relationship it's probably because
you're being told what to do it's
probably because you feel like you got
handcuffs on and you can't do the thing
that you want to do however you define
freedom though that's gonna be the path
through to solving all the major
problems in your life wherever you are
not happy and the same thing applies to
your business the same thing applies to
your relationships in your career the
same thing applies to every single
aspect of your life when you figure out
who you are when you figure out what
your one word most important value is
when you stop asking for other people's
approval permission guidance and they're
telling you what to do when you take
ownership and accountability for where
you are in life that's when things start
to change so how do you figure out how
to know yourself how do you figure out
what your purpose should be I'm gonna
give you the 3-step process I call it
the purpose planner and through these
exercises if you take them seriously and
write them down and spend five minutes
figuring this stuff out you are set up
for life I think it's a worthwhile
exercise I hope you'll do it with me
let's go
step number one is find your whoo you
have to figure out what your who is and
that's your one word most important core
value you can go through the book those
exercises there but think about what is
your most important core value who you
have always been and who you always will
be
the rock that you stand on doesn't
matter necessarily what you're doing yet
doesn't matter your activities yet it's
you on a human value basis I think every
human being has a single most important
core value that everything else flows
through so if you had to define yourself
in one word the thing that means that
most to you what would that be figure
out your who step number two is figure
out your why what's your why why do you
do what you do I believe that your
purpose comes from your pain that the
thing that you are doing the thing that
bring you the most
satisfaction in latina fills your soul
up comes from actually the deepest pain
in your life so why do I love helping
entrepreneurs because I struggled so
much as an entrepreneur because if you
ask me when did I feel the most
worthless in my life it was when I was
starting up my first business when I was
19 years old I was making $300 a month I
was barely able to survive I told my
business partner that I quit meanwhile
I'm telling my friends that I can't hang
out with them because I'm living the
entrepreneurial life meanwhile I can't
afford to twenty bucks to go out for
pizza and beer like I felt worthless and
so ask yourself when did you feel the
most worthless in your life because I
believe that humans are built to serve
and the more that you figure out what
your most painful moment in your life
was the best way that you can serve is
to help other people avoid that same
fate to help other people who are going
through that thing that you went through
and give them a little bit of guidance
give them a little support give them a
little belief your purpose comes from
your pain that is your why and it's your
most important step number two step
number three is figure out your how
so we have our who we have our why now
it's our how for me my who is my one
word believe my why is the pain that I
went through as an entrepreneur so I
want to help other entrepreneurs but how
do I do it how do you do the thing that
you are meant to go off and do for me
helping entrepreneurs there's a lot of
ways I could do it there's a lot of ways
that I could do it if your internet goes
down I could come over to your house or
your basement or your garage and help
you set up your internet and then you're
back online and now you're off running
your business and I feel great about the
result I feel great that now you are
back online and able to go sell your
products and services awesome I don't
like the process I don't like the how I
don't want to have to come and
troubleshoot and log into your computer
and call technical support with your
internet provider I don't want to do
that stuff and so it's really important
this is where a lot of entrepreneurs
fall down you enjoy the result you enjoy
the result of your work because it's
tied to your pain right you figured out
your why you've enjoyed the result but
you don't enjoy the process you don't
enjoy the process of getting to the
result and the most successful people in
the world they enjoy the process they
love playing the game not just the
results of the game and so what I want
you to do is write down a list
of all the things that you have done
that you felt great about the result the
tie-in to your passion right the tie-in
to your why for me helping entrepreneurs
I would make a list of all the different
ways that I have helped entrepreneurs
that I felt great about the result so
you make a list make a list 10 15 20
deep of all the things you've done that
you feel great about the result then
look at that list this is where the how
comes in look at that list and ask
yourself which of these that I actually
enjoy the process of doing and not just
the result and your the result and
enjoyed the process that's your house
that's what you want to do for the rest
of your life so that's the purpose
planner that's a three step process
figure out your who figure out your why
figure out your how I think is one of
the most important exercises that you
can ever do in your life and going
through will give you a ton of extra
clarity so that you can know yourself
and plan a better future for the decades
left on your life to go out and have a
major impact now I've got a really
special bonus clip for you that I think
you're gonna enjoy but before that
question of the day I want to know what
is your one word and how has it changed
your actions let me know put it in the
comments below a lot of times people are
sort of like these are the seven habits
of highly creative people they do this
they get up early in the morning they
write 800 words a day then you know and
it's and you're like oh that's what I
need to do and then I'll be highly
creative know what I found and I think
it's just irrefutable true is that there
is no magic one-size-fits-all solution
when it comes to habits or happiness or
anything and then we always have to
begin by saying like what's true for us
so you might say oh you know I get up at
5:00 a.m. and right and my 5 to 7:00
a.m. is you know it's quiet my mind is
fresh I just done my meditate it's like
amazing this is what everybody should do
but it's like well some people are night
people and they're not at their most
creative until 4:00 p.m. so for them to
get up early and try to write it's like
nonsensical it does it's just not right
for them it's not that you're wrong or
they're wrong it's just that people are
different and so when you're trying to
have create your habits it's really
important to start by saying well what
kind of person am I what's true about me
you know and like another thing that
comes up is simplicity lovers and
abundance lovers simplicity lovers like
clean surfaces
bare walls you know quiet fuse choices
and that's how they feel like they can
they have focus and creativity and
energy abundance levers like a lot of
buzz a lot of profusion a lot of choices
people running around a lot going on
there's nothing wrong with that either
and a lot of times people are like if
you're gonna be creative you have to
clean up your desk it's not it's not
necessarily true and I'm sure you've
seen that all the amazing book Mason
Mason craze book daily rituals but is
all about the habits of the like super
super genius people and what you see
they're all over the place
they're all over the place so one
person's gets up early and one person
stays up late one person drinks coffee
and one person tree so I can one person
works in a crowd and one person works
over themselves and one person works a
half an hour a day like Gertrude Stein
and other person works 14 hours a day
like PG Wodehouse I mean it's like
there's just you can't prescribe you
have to begin by knowing yourself and so
I think that's the first thing for
people to do is say well what do I
recognize when do I do my best work when
am I succeeded in the past what attracts
me what a what idea attracts me does it
attract me the idea that I would get up
at 5:00 and maybe that maybe that sounds
great
or maybe that says look at that you know
even you just sort of think about it I
think a lot of times we just we're sort
of again we're kind of adrift and we're
reacting instead of saying like what's
true for me how should I shape my
environment like my schedule as much as
I can to see myself is it fair to say
that in Gretchen Rubens world that step
one is knowing yourself yes that fair
okay if you want more dhandapani check
out the top 10 rules video I made on him
the link is right there next to me I
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there
concentration willpower practice yes all
those are important those are the
ingredients but how much do you want it